better business outcomes come from an
engaged workforce that is constantly
evolving the right learning culture is
essential we work with the world's
leading thinkers to bring you their
expertise to drive change in your
organization our content will increase
the return on investment in your
internal learning and communication
programs our experts combined
cutting-edge knowledge with proven
strategies for success courses are
tailored to the needs of each group
within your organization your people
tell your story and know your mission
best just think about the power of
somebody seeing your face and your voice
giving a message to every employee in
your company that is so much more
powerful than just a written memo
there's good content here it's in a
easily digestible form i think i
understand what i can get and that's a
quality interaction bigthink edge
delivers comprehensive program design
and production support to develop
lessons with your best internal experts
our multimedia content modules are
customizable delivery is flexible an
integration into your learning culture
is seamless and fast the most effective
businesses are there people with
essential knowledge to thrive if you are
in any kind of leadership position I
would strongly advise using video
messages rather than a written messages
I also believe in immersing yourself
with people the best in the world at
what they do because there are these
little 10 millimeter shifts these little
slight differences that the best on
earth know that it may have taken them
10 20 30 years to figure out but it
gives them a geometric difference in the
results that they can produce let your
people know that you are committed to
their development bring them learning
from the best with big think edge
you